welcome to this video playing Annie ma
and aman wear an abaya that sounds wrong
anyway from Finland yeah do I go from my
book line let's do it at least I've got
quite some experience there and well and
some knowledge I guess ambition cotuit
prescribed main line yeah III is the
move now okay you can play g3 or what
not I mean lots of things are possible
but a three years by far the most common
ok hijo
okay 594 is interesting match be okay
right Queen a for that that's really an
unknown position now tween 84 is
nonsense due to Bishop d7 for 1c 294 84
Queen day for Bishop d7 queen bee 40c3
nice really quick and playing that okay
so takes there at the end I will take
you form so what do I take with with the
night probably for the discoveries or
queen takes now in 20 eggs is kind of
slightly awkward for him what is he
playing then be should be to where i can
even castle long which is completely
weird in that opening but can night XD
for is also interested yet let's let's
play move and not think about it too
long i can take g2 he probably were cast
along then i want to i want to make sure
that he is not cancelling so easily okay
it took their and quickly well okay
let's have a look here queen Queenie 523
you probably has Queen d2 now which
seems kind of okay
hmm what's the best square it's not so
clear checking rethrick this is probably
also not bad check getting the Queen to
age three I know I didn't want to put it
on a dark square because of Queen d2 and
always there were the trades and turn
yeah i thought this should be rather
okay here I've have something you on the
e-file and Queen g2 is also sometimes
quite disturbing I hope well going back
now what am i doing doubling on the
e-file order between g2's quincy to a
move on it's probably not leading to
much they have it it's a bit slightly
annoying let's do it if you move the
bishop noel tf3 so i can probably um or
two each sound let's go to the seven
okay I didn't see that move coming
that's a good one hmm okay jam that I
probably don't have anything you check
okay I mean I also don't have a problem
but it I thought I really had ways to
play for us for something here in front
advantage it's not down so let's see how
to play that can I do something against
his pawns there
probably not probably not I mean white
also cannot do much so it's a very sound
structure here I mean the double points
all nice and fine but where are you
going to ever get there I don't think
that this is possible okay I think I'm
going here yeah I wanted to provoke be
three that's useful for me to have
heaven more pawns on light squares and
maybe you can go a 4 here and try to
claim that I'm zoosk one with my bishop
oh that could be an idea I missed that
idea a four is good whoo yeah okay
thatthat's not leading anywhere i think
a force was pretty strong i saw that far
too late far too late
I know I'm okay again I wonder how do i
play if he I mean you probably won't
take do I am play okay well you have to
go back first to have King g7 handy i
wonder if i should go before or or
taking taking i might get around to
activate that bishop let's do this and
but before it's also interesting for a
for a three bishop a for those kind of
ideas the breakthrough ideas mmm it
still might be some kind of selves oops
wrong if i do that before a four and so
on that can prove to be morally tricky
ticking is probably the healthy option
at this it's intuitive i really like to
play for that idea let's do it I don't
think I'm risking much there
but ok I only have 40 seconds so i just
have to hope that i'm right with this I
can do that pre movie probably won't
play it but in any case
now Bishop a4 is threatened that's very
serious I'll just see prevent that you I
don't see it King f4 Bishop a four tix
b3 and over how does it prevent that am
I really winning with that simple trick
Bishop Bishop f4 right takes be three
yeah it's just winning what's the point
yeah so that that simple trick actually
I got in white resign yeah I'm not sure
really I mean ok I made a big mistake I
think with when we this is just nothing
going on now that there's nothing for
from its just equal I think it's funny
that the engine gives away the big
advantage I think I think this is kind
of kind of kind of weird anyway um I
think I made a pretty substantial
mistake with the CSA it was a mistake I
have to go bishop be aid and then I
already been ready for b5 b3 and now a
four winds here as I suspected yeah i'm
i'm super swanky a kid but i cannot move
that Bishop if i move it he will take
and tea I'm running out of moves and I'm
losing that pawn then so I don't have
that move and the only thing that I can
do is I can go here and now he just
zoosk wang's me and that's it yeah it
was that was very simple but I saw it
too late I was thinking Bishop aphorism
I had that idea in mind at the end right
I wanted to probe B 3 and then get
exactly the the winning thing up but I
didn't see I didn't think about a 4
initially because it looks kind of
counterintuitive to put more on light
squares but it's of course just good
because my bishop and yeah my bishop is
is totally stuck there was a huge
mistake Bishop a form so he allowed that
and I think he it's it's it's equal
again went over here no to you yeah
maybe this is risky and I'm really not
sure be a fall and yeah that that's
winning now yeah after this he has no no
defense he has to do something kinja for
I has to be ready to go back and now the
computer says I'm losing why am I
getting spanked again that's maybe true
I asked I suspected that this is kind of
risky I'm still getting zoosk want that
plane is really far too recklessly
remarkable well i mean this this is
still a suit swagga he goes here and
it's not a big difference if the porn is
on a 40 hm huh really jet engine gives
this move which is still kind of
interesting yeah King takes losses so
Bishop takes and now I get get out here
a little bit is this somehow better
they're probably not home and so then
this this was a whole bunch of smoke and
mirrors that that thing I have to here
here here I have to check on c4 probably
or stay I mean that's probably also okay
just just stay and be okay with with
some kind of draw okay that's one
interesting endgame thanks for watching